this defiant group of students is taking
a stand against the Taliban withdrawing
their education they say their Ambitions
and dreams cannot be taken from them
in the 21st century if there is no
education we will vanish from the face
of the Earth no one is going to take us
seriously and we won't be able to demand
our rights only with education can we
understand our rights and
responsibilities
this was the notification of an
indefinite ban on Women's University
education
a gynecologist in Kabul says a lack of
female doctors could put lives in danger
if there is no schools no universities
and no gynecology
or their female doctors the number of
MMR or maternity mortality rate is
increasing day by day
despite strong condemnation from several
countries and activist groups the
Taliban is yet to respond officially but
sources have told Al Jazeera the Taliban
is divided between reformers many of
whom engage with the International
Community during talks in Dohan and a
more conservative faction one analyst
says the decisions are made by small
minority currently the division is
within the government those Taliban
leaders who negotiated peace with the US
and Doha and Doha Qatar they are not
against women education there's only
five people who are managing the whole
team these are the hardliners and they
are not typically Kabul mostly they are
stationed in Kandahar more than a year
before the Taliban took power in
Afghanistan its first Deputy leader
Sarah Jordan hakani wrote an article
published in the New York Times
it said women's rights to education
would be protected a promise that has
been rolled back but the U.S also failed
on its promise to use economic tools as
leverage to moderate the Taliban in 2021
it froze nearly 10 billion dollars in
assets belonging to the Afghan Central
Bank women say they're still suffering
please don't put more sanctions than
Afghanistan the each sanction you put on
we are having the result I mean when I
say we it's women who are like they are
eliminating women they are giving us
poison each time many women say they
were shocked by the announcement I was
really shocked I couldn't have believed
that there were some rumors that they
are going to ban girls from attending
universities but we didn't know that
this will happen in the middle of their
finals and they won't let these guys
graduate for the moment scenes like this
women walking to University hoping to
shape their career paths will stop for
the foreseeable future
Laura Khan Al Jazeera